so uh donald trump just said that drug
dealers should be put to death
and uh i guess the question is
what what degree is he talking about
because he mentions these other
countries and he says china doesn't have
a drug problem and i'm like is he
talking about you know drug cartels that
are murdering people and dealing in this
really hard stuff or is he talking about
like singapore level
if you're found with like a poppy seed
on you they lock you up maybe not that
extreme obviously but uh
interesting nonetheless because
immediately everyone's kind of like dude
a lot of trump's supporters are fairly
libertarian so it's interesting to see
but i think this is what's more
interesting about the conversation is
what what rhetoric trump will embrace as
we move into the midterms
and whether or not he'll announce before
or after so he got that story plus the
washington post says that trump's
actions are being investigated and it's
such a vague weasley headline are they
investigating trump or not come on come
out tell us if trump is being
investigated they said there is a
criminal investigation and trump's
actions are involved which sounds to me
like they're saying okay it's not going
to be trump and then we got another
funny story democrats are boycotting
hulu because hulu won't let them run the
political ads they want to oh did you
get what you wished for when you didn't
want political ads on these platforms or
when you wanted censorship because now
you can't run your ads yeah keep crying
about it my friends before we get
started head over to timcast.com the
latest members only from the tim cast
uncensored after our show was hanging
out with zubi you want to check this out
it's a really interesting show the link
is in the description below you can also
check out our show tales from the
inverted world as a member you are
supporting our work directly and we got
a lot of fun and crazy stuff happening
of course you know that i took out a
96-foot billboard of my rooster roberto
jr in times square among other
billboards and uh we're really excited
that we're going to be doing this big
marketing push and we're going to be
asserting ourselves in these dominant
cultural spaces and it's with your
support we can keep doing that we're
gonna have a members only show coming up
tonight which should be particularly
particularly interesting considering our
guest is former a.g matt whitaker
hello
so how are you this is amazing thanks
for coming now yeah former attorney
general i was looking for a way to tank
my career i think i found it
your career's not taken off
so well this is what happens when you
lose a bet and with cash you know what
happened yeah cash and our friends we
were playing some golf and uh he said
whoever makes this putt you know if you
miss it you got to you know go on tim
cass and so here i am i'll take it no so
i'm glad to be here thank you give a
brief introduction for yourself your
work hello i'm matt whitaker former
acting attorney general united states
and as my friend simon conway on who in
des moines iowa which is what the radio
station that ronald reagan was on in des
moines always says
former hawkeye legend because i played
football at the university of iowa and
all-around good guy there you go you
played the guitar earlier too yeah i'm
not very good i mean i haven't i have a
guitar i have guitars it's really kind
of sad um and every uh probably six
months i determined like this is going
to be the time when i pick it back up
and and get back into it and then i
realized like you know i'm it it's hard
work like anything else yeah i'm really
interested to hear about the the inner
workings in your work as acting attorney
general so thanks for coming man this
would be a blast
we've also got mary morgan happy to be
back i know you're all happy to see me
hello it's me mary from pop culture
crisis on youtube i urge you to go
subscribe i'm here to dutifully chill
for the show today
we talk about entertainment news movies
celebrities go join us
uh hi everyone ian crossland here as
well good to see you from ian
crossland.net good to meet you matt good
to meet you appreciate it i'm i'm
tremendously envious of your hair oh
thanks and i don't say that very often
but i mean i i if i had had hair like
that or did have hair like that i would
be
more likely in a heavy metal band than a
former attorney general so life takes
different turns based on the skills and
abilities you're given speak the truth
brother
let's get down to it that's right i'm
delighted to have matt this evening
really excited to hear about what he
went through in the white house and i
can't wait to get into it let's go so
here's the first story we got from
newsweek trump urges death penalty for
drug dealers quote china has no drug
problem
they say trump made the remarks in a
speech he delivered in vegas las vegas
nevada friday during a rally for his
endorsed candidates in the state's
gubernatorial and senate races the
speech was marked by two recurring
themes for trump a demand for law and
order as well as an admiration for
heavy-handed governance he said quote if
you look at countries all throughout the
world the only ones that don't have a
drug problem are those that institute
the death penalty for drug dealers
they're the only ones you understand
that china has no drug problem during a
speech trump recalled asking chinese
president xi jinping if his country had
a drug problem quote i innocently and
perhaps naively asked if there was much
of a drug problem in china why would you
ask he didn't say this but i'm saying
what he was thinking why would you have
such a dumb question is that no no no we
don't have a drug problem why would we
have a drug problem there is no problem
drug dealers get the death penalty the
trial goes very quickly so instead of
coming to ch into china they go
someplace else we've had big drug
problems over the centuries but we don't
have a drug problem at all now they
don't deal in china the former president
said so matt you're you're actually
there right so so he said that he he
gave us similar remarks just today oh
okay um
i got the old version of the story yeah
america
first
agenda conference put on by america
first policy institute which i run i'm
co-chair of their center for law and
justice and yes i this is not he's he
said this actually while he was
president as well this is a theme that
i've heard from donald trump many times
and
you know
i think his his sentiment
is
spot-on if you look at uh the opioid uh
you know fentanyl drug overdose crisis
in our country we we're we're losing
over a hundred thousand people a year
now in our country
uh two overdoses yeah in fact um
you know more people
die of uh it's the number one killer uh
from for 18 to 45. but these are
prescribed aren't they not fentanyl
no no so the the prescription opioids
are a much smaller segment now what's
what's actually happening
is um you know people are
that
you you've my understanding and again
i'm i'm not a drug user not a drug
dealer have never used an illegal drug
and so
uh my understanding and talking to the
experts and talking to people is is that
it you build up a tolerance to opioids
and fentanyl and opioids the synthetic
opioid and so if you don't um if you
don't either don't take it it's laced in
something else you take or if you you
know take too much of it that it can
just you know pretty much
wipe you out now this is not you know
we also thought about at the department
of justice you know we reinstituted the
death penalty
um
because it had been a moratorium since
the bush administration on the death
penalty and one of the things we thought
about was using fentanyl
as as the lethal agent um
in order to demonstrate kind of the
lethality is that a word yes yes
um i'm sure people watching are gonna
you know and
get in uh an inner comment to tell me if
it is or isn't but no it is only you can
see that um
but you know the to to demonstrate just
how potent fentanyl can be but uh so
what does it do like when you when you
overdose on fentanyl you just kind of
pass out is that what happens
yeah it's essentially it it
my understanding is it takes your you
know your vitals down to zero i mean you
just kind of like it like it depresses
your you know your your pull your heart
and your lungs and you stop breathing
and you you know essentially sounds i
mean in terms of the death penalty that
sounds humane at the very least yeah and
it's pretty much what we're doing with
an another cocktail of drugs and we you
know we um i'll give you an example i
mean i know you don't want to do a show
about the death penalty and so uh i i
want to keep this it should be lighter
because i'm usually a fun person but
this is so dark yeah it's really dark
and i'm not a dark person i'm an
optimist but you know we um
in the state of iowa my my home state um
i was the u.s attorney in the southern
district of iowa there's a northern
district which i actually have if you
have a southern district that implies a
northern district but in the northern
district of iowa we had had a drug
dealer um who
executed a family of five
and including the mom and dad and and
the kids and so that he was sentenced
rightfully to the death penalty and that
has been had been sitting
in prison for over 20 years
because there was this de facto
moratorium even though congress had said
and the president signed a law saying
there is a death penalty in in federal
system for certain things you know they
weren't they weren't doing it and you
know the biden administration is now not
doing it either but he this gentleman
from iowa
um
was
you know put to death under the federal
system in the trump administration and
it was um i knew a prosecutor who had
done that case and had been around for
20 years waiting to see that and he
actually called me that day and and and
thanked me and thanked the
administration for you know finally
giving that family that was still alive
you know justice but so so going to
trump's comments and just to clarify
the article i actually the article that
i had sourced because we had a couple of
them and i made this mistake was that
trump said this more than once he said
it a couple weeks ago and he said it
again we've we have a story here from
three hours ago trump calls for a quick
death penalty for drug dealers this one
is actually the headline is more overt
and so uh
in his first speech back in washington
since he left the presidency he called
for a quick death i don't know that
feels a little heavy-handed right a drug
dealer like to what degree are we
talking about yeah well i mean i'm not
going to try to morally um justify a
certain levels of drug dealing and
compare and contrast that to others
if you know anything about drug dealing
it's always a pyramid scheme right you
have the the street level drug dealers
uh that are you know usually the ones
that are taken out and then you have
different levels and oftentimes in my
experience about two steps two hops get
you to a mexican drug cartel and so
if you're talking about kingpins we
already have kingpin statutes uh they
don't call for the death penalty my
understanding and again i don't i'm not
the trump whisperer i've spent a lot of
time with him i heard his remarks today
my belief is that he really
wants to target the head of the snake
the kingpins uh the ones that are
getting rich and uh you know kind of the
pablo escobar types
not the street level hustler um not that
they're not any more
less morally responsible for this
scourge of uh you know of illicit drugs
in our system um you know we need to
have a bigger conversation also um
congress has been completely uh
unavailable and uninvolved in you know
the regulation of drugs
you know we the states have taken it on
uh and you know mostly deregulated uh
marijuana for example i don't you know
this is again this isn't the topic that
we're talking about but i have a lot of
strong feelings on this
and um
you know i the federal government
is needs to do one of two things
either join the states or most of the
states and have congress you know pass a
law that that reclassifies marijuana or
start enforcing the law what we can't
have is these laws that aren't enforced
that you know because it's because you
know what we need and the rule of law
for it to work is certainty uh for
citizens i think it should be i think
shapat should be illegal but um i think
you get bigger challenges when you get
into harder stuff fentanyl especially is
getting laced into all these drugs
and then you know to be honest uh i
oppose that i oppose a death penalty
because
you know
the best example i can give to people is
kamala harris deciding who gets to die
doesn't sound good to me at all i
understand that there are really bad
people like the guy you mentioned right
so tim let's let's let me just
the way
the death penalty works is the jury that
the peers the 12 people that decide
whether the person's guilty or not
decide the penalty phase and whether or
not they have the death penalty so so to
seek the death penalty that's about the
only thing that actually the attorney
general united states can do and only
can do everything else has been can or
has been delegated in the department of
justice but but the one thing that the
attorney general has to do is determine
whether or not to seek the death penalty
um you know in these cases and we did we
spent a lot of time i mean you i i
that is the most um
difficult
decision uh that an attorney general i
think has to make is whether or not to
seek
the death penalty and you know you get
these recommendations from the u.s
attorney's office all over the country
some are you know less uh likely to
pursue the death penalty some are more
likely to pursue the death penalty but
it's just the the cases are just the
worst of the worst i mean you know it's
it's it's you're just like oh my god i
mean this can't you know this fact
pattern is the worst i've ever seen then
you read the next one it's like oh my
goodness and this is this is even more
horrible the challenge is
look you know you you hear a story you
read
the the details about it and you're like
this person
you know can't be rehabilitated they're
truly a violent sociopath but proven
beyond a reasonable doubt i don't know
if i trust the state to get it right and
then the issue is you know to quote
benjamin franklin is better than 100
guilty persons escaped than one innocent
person suffer the idea to me that the
state would say look we believe these
facts to be true to the best of our
abilities and you might have uh good
people who are like this guy did brutal
things to a family and we we can't have
this remain that i totally get and
saying you know so we are going to this
person has forfeit their life by taking
the lives of others the issue i guess is
just that
there's a percentage of people who are
innocent who are going to be killed by
the state and
i don't know man i'm not going to
pretend to have the answers but i can
just tell you i just don't like the idea
yeah i mean obviously
the system has built in tremendous
safeguards at least in the federal
system like you know there's some states
and throughout american history i think
you know that the safeguards weren't
there but as you know and i'm talking
about you know my experience is in
federal court and in federal law and you
know as it relates to the death penalty
the federal death penalty and there are
um
there are a lot of safeguards built in
but you know i i do share that that it
would you know obviously we'd rather
uh you know have a hundred people have
life in prison
than have one you know person get the
death penalty and have be executed that
you know was innocent
yeah let me so you know it's a tough
area but i know this we're not you know
yes mary is the purpose of the death
penalty then
to
seek retribution for victims and
enact justice or is it
simply by necessity to remove this
person from society and any chance that
they could escape prison because at this
point we're releasing so many criminals
i'm not sure where i stand on it
yeah i mean there's a lot of reasons we
have uh you know criminal prosecution
and criminal punishment you know
retribution is one reason punishment is
another reason uh you know excluding the
death penalty rehabilitation
um is another reason that you know we
have uh criminal penalties
you know so i've spent i'm not in the
legislature i was never in the
legislature and so you know my kind of i
haven't done the balancing test on on on
this as to you know sort of where but
congress has passed a law that says
there is a certain
category of crimes that is that is
eligible for the death penalty and
here's the process and so um you know as
a as a prosecutor and as of the former
you know acting attorney general we we
executed the laws
i didn't have i didn't have to decide
and i don't think it's appropriate
actually that's why these moratoriums
i think take you know the the people
through their representatives have
passed this law you your representatives
the people you voted for have passed
this law or have not repealed it more
importantly and so you know let's put
that on the ballot let's make that an
issue let's look that you know if the
people don't want the death penalty more
tim to your point is let you know let's
let's vote for it that's what i never
understand
and this is what the left loves to do is
they love to have the executive branch
under their under their you know leaders
like joe biden
um you know decide that certain things
aren't you know morally reprehensible
but they'll never take the vote because
you know that mostly the american people
are on it are in a different place on it
republicans don't seem to do anything
about it i mean yeah i mean that's 2016
through 18 and they just let russia gate
happen
they did um you know i was i got there
in october of 2017 and uh you know not a
day went by that somehow
the russian collusion fable didn't
affect you know the department of
justice because it was if you remember
people you want to forget because it was
such a
a
negative uh you know just
bs i know i can't say what i want to say
but it was such because
ultimately every night it was just some
new revelation some leaker had said you
know some
fbi agent or sources or you know it's
just it's just this constant drum beat
of stories that in retrospect were all
fake news yep and so you can totally
when you know donald trump says you know
and points to the back of the room and
says you guys are fake news i mean they
are
they are let me pull up this story we
got from the washington post this is uh
relatively nebulous i suppose justice
department investigating trump's actions
in january 6 criminal probe people
familiar with the probe said
investigators are examining the former
president's conversations and seized
phone records of top aides
what they don't say is
is trump the target of this criminal
probe no the washington post post just
says trump's actions
it doesn't even say they're
investigating trump himself they may be
passively referring to while trump said
this one thing what does that have to do
with it and i guarantee you right now
there's a panel on msnbc wringing their
hands and john dean's on there talking
about you know sort of his experience
with nixon it's it's just a you know and
i mean it's just it's it's it's a trail
of morons quite frankly that that then
will jump on a story like that and and
immediately wildly speculate
not only as to that trump is the target
they'll say
not knowing and then
they will
usually uh immediately convict him and
you know suggest you know again say the
worst possible things about him it's
it's got to be infuriating well so this
this is this is never ending i mean
russiagate was a farce it was a hoax
how come none of these people are being
held to account
i mean
high ranking individuals signing off on
this stuff
look you're you know you were uh i think
you were in for about how long were you
for about a year as acting ag uh four
months four months much less i spanned
to 2018 and 2019 so oh okay yeah looks
better on my resume right that must be
what i saw well so i'm wondering in your
in your experience then i mean you're
you're there at sag why isn't
why isn't why hasn't anyone done
anything about this i mean do you think
if if trump wins in 2024 maybe there
will be some accountability for for the
lies i mean i hope when you had cash on
here he talked about his his durham
watch and you know sort of what john
durham is or isn't doing uh you saw how
difficult the michael sussman
prosecution were i mean it was very
clear that that that he had lied to the
fbi and and a jury in the district of
columbia is never going to convict you
know right uh somebody in that situation
well so i mean that goes back to my
death penalty comments yeah right you
get you get someone who's a trump
supporter suspected of a very serious
heinous crime you put him in dc they're
going to be like kill him yeah that's
horrifying
and and that's that two-tier system of
justice is something that i'm i'm
talking about a lot right now we have
um there's no doubt that the left it
gets away you know you think about the
riots in 2020 and compare that to
january 6. um you know you i'm sure that
um you know some smart lawyer could
could parse the difference but but it's
really not it's it's political violence
um you know if if those people outside
the white house that burned you know the
church
uh right across the street from the
white house if they had you know they
were trying to get into the white house
you know they had to build dramatic you
know sort of night after night they kept
trying to push the perimeter out first
of all and build higher fences to keep
those folks i mean there were their
police officers were assaulted uh you
know there was no doubt about that
during those riots and so so and no i
don't i mean again i i'm i'm gonna make
a bold statement here but but certainly
those folks that participated in that
over the course of the summer in
washington dc and looted georgetown and
and just you know you know
did all sorts of of things
nobody was prosecuted to the extent that
the people that participated in january
6 and i'm saying both those should be
treated the same like political violence
is never acceptable but in this case the
american people see the different
treatment of those folks i i've talked
to people they have no idea what 529 is
i mean we i talk to people all the time
and i say you know what are your
thoughts on when they try when the the
529 you know riots when they set fire to
a guard post when they torched the
church and tore the barricades down the
president was forced in a bunker they go
i didn't know that happened because the
media you don't have well there's a 529
commission i mean right
yeah no no no no but and and that's my
point
before the show you mentioned that at
some point it's just not worth it to get
paid 170 000 a year to have your life
destroyed by the establishment by the
unit party by the democrats and so i
wonder if that's the reason why you
don't get a 529 commission why
republicans seem to do very little if
anything at all yeah
well i think you know in
the next year um i expect that there
will be a lot more i mean i think the
the right is learning that we can't sit
by and play you know patty cake while
the left tries to destroy literally uh
our entire society and people you know
everybody's reputation i mean i think
there is just a finally final
realization that
we can't
not fight uh you know we'd prefer to
actually um you know have a civil
dialogue and have a discussion and have
the marketplace of ideas that's supposed
to work and convince people to you vote
for us and vote against them but but i
think there is a realization now that
the left is just in it
to win it and not only to win it but but
but like destroy everything in their
path for for the sake of power but
there's there's see you know when uh
you're you're acting a g i mean they
came after you pretty hard i'd imagine
right yeah
absolutely republicans don't do that to
democrats
look at brett kavanaugh i mean the
psychotic behavior they accused the man
of lining up at frat parties to
gang
assault women yeah in these
ridiculousness
pirate ship going up and down the coast
wasn't there some story about that yeah
i mean it was just it was like nonsense
someone literally fabricated a story
about him on some boat doing something
to a woman and then they were like yeah
we made the whole thing up where are the
republicans accusing democrats of doing
anything they don't and then when when
you get people like james lindsey for
instance and he starts referring to
people targeting children as groomers
twitter bans the word and big tech comes
in immediate defense of the left so
there's no collateral damage for the
democrats and the left to engage in this
behavior the right does not do anything
to combat it and so you look at the
republican party i mean half the time
they're in agreements or look at this we
just had how many republicans come out
supporting gun control which is wildly
unpopular among the republican voter
base they don't care you know i look at
people like shelley shelly moore capital
in west virginia she's not a for
re-election for another like five years
so so what does she care she's probably
laughing all the way to the bank as she
torches her constituents this is what we
keep getting so i mean
man is it brutal to watch yeah now now
you have the january 6 committee on tv
they're calling it a tv show the season
finale they're lying about basically
everything
and people are are wrapped up in this
cult they believe this stuff
and you know there's so much we can talk
about on the
uh that committee or whatever whatever
you want to call it i mean it's a
one-sided show trial like you would see
in a uh
a dictatorship in the and you know there
did we get outplayed in sort of the
straight you know the the chess match of
who should have been on the committee
and you know if they wouldn't put jim
jordan should we at least had some
non-anti-trumpers on this to at least
you know bring a different you know
narrative or a different you know
thrust of the questioning
right now it is um
it's the only thing the left has and
that's that's what's just fascinating to
me i mean if you look at uh what the two
things that the left has is they have uh
the dobbs opinion
uh and and you know essentially claiming
uh making falsehoods about what actually
dobbs is and stands for which is the
overturning of roe v wade and returning
the issue to the people into the states
um but then their other issue is january
6th and and you know and some false
narrative about um this you know mass
conspiracy i i don't even i don't know
what they're trying i mean they're just
trying to destroy people and and and
leave they just mass chaos in its wake
they use this manipulative technique
where
when something happens we don't know at
the time of a circumstance what is
happening so uh 911 for example
there's a lot of people who like to look
at footage from 911 and then claim it's
proof of a conspiracy and it's like hold
on the reason you get conflicting
reports in in some of the circumstances
because at the time everyone was
confused as to what was really going on
a guy who was on the north who was in
the financial district didn't know
exactly what was happening on the upper
west side and so people were getting
conflicting information across the board
and thus news reports come out and they
conflict now whatever you want to
believe on that stuff i'm not getting
into the nitty-gritty my point is
on january 6 the people who were let
into the building many of them had no
idea i'd say most of them probably had
no idea there was fighting happening on
the other side cops opened up the
barricades fanned them in doors were
opened cops fanned them in one guy was
acquitted of all charges because of that
that guy did not know that the other
side of the building
couldn't see it people were beating cops
and fighting and throwing things so what
happens is
hindsight the democrats look at the most
egregious moments
show everyone that footage and then say
everybody in that building that's them
right there and people go wow
well and you know what they're also
doing in addition to those 800 and some
people that have been charged with with
you know
all sorts of various crimes including
illegal entering of a secured facility
they then say all 1.5 million people in
washington dc that day are
insurrectionist
i mean you know people that weren't even
close to the capital are you know are
are suddenly swept in and then they
taken the next logical step which is all
of you trump supporters are are the
equivalent of the people that were you
know assaulting police officers and
that's just right we know that's not
true but you know again there's nobody
on this committee to to give a counter
narrative or to explain exactly what you
just said which is it all depends on
what part of the elephant you're
you're
examining yeah i think the fair point is
to be a little bit optimistic is that uh
the only thing they have is january 6
and americans don't care about it at all
yeah i mean you look at gas prices
inflation
people care much much more about that
and the news coming out of there is joe
biden's going to be selling off 20
million more barrels of our strategic
petroleum reserve
gutting the system i think he's doing it
to be honest um because he wants to se
he wants europe to be able to buy oil
from us because russia's cutting them
off or fuel i should say russia's
cutting off their gas yeah but if the
left was you know really believed that
they needed to help europe
uh joe biden on day one would have said
to
merkel and angela merkel at the time you
need to keep building those liquid
natural gas terminals uh and really if
they shut down their nuclear power yeah
they've they've done everything to
increase their dependency on russia and
uh the fact that they didn't see this
coming
um you know is is naive at the worst and
intentional you know really as the truth
it sounds intentional i think
it sure looks like i can't this is one
of those things that you know i i i so
my experience is being a federal
prosecutor uh you know sort of being a
you know
someone that's run for public office
twice in iowa and so you know my
um you know it's just in israel but you
know sort of the the geo the real
politic of some of these global issues
um you know i apply reason and common
sense and they just it doesn't add up
you know what germany
did over the last decade to end up in
this situation with russia i don't
understand but maybe they just maybe
they nev didn't believe that russia was
and putin was as evil as he is we had
zubi on the other day he said he thinks
to control demolition that he sees
what's happening it's intentional and i
said you know i'll give you an example
they say there's going to be a food
shortage because of the war with russia
ukraine and russia aren't exporting
wheat anymore russia is not exporting
fertilizer
then the government of the netherlands
tells their farmers to stop farming the
uk and ireland tell their farmers to
stop farming how does that make sense it
doesn't not at all i wonder if the real
reason they're telling their farmers not
to farm is because they want to reserve
fuel for the war effort or in
preparation for something like that
we got a lot of we got a people people
eat a lot of food we got a major
abundance of food so maybe the thinking
is
tell the farmers oh it's climate change
you got to stop and then what that does
is reduces the amount of consumption uh
fossil fuels of oil they use we could
divert that into other areas maybe i
don't know but i'll tell you this it's
all intentional
that to me is an objective fact you
can't tell people the food shortage is
coming we're all going to starve to
death hey stop farming yeah
so you remember um
oh i don't when 20 years ago when there
was no iphone 20 years ago where you two
2007 15. yeah i mean so so
i mean maybe 10 years ago i don't know
i'm not a technologist but i have an
iphone 2005 six is when there's no okay
that's right okay so less than 20 years
ago and um this is the this is what
surprises me about human beings we're so
innovative we're always trying to to to
to solve problems and to make you know
life easier and and to do all these
things and yet you know in an iphone
less than 20 years ago we didn't have
iphones um
and think about what you can do with an
iphone i mean it's just extraordinary
even though you don't track you and does
everything you know all these insidious
things too but
somehow energy is different than an
iphone that we won't evolve that we
won't you know there won't be new
technologies there won't be better ways
to you know sort of you know
drive tractors and push cars around and
all the all the things we use fossil
fuels for i just i just i am i believe
in american innovation and and
especially americans but human
innovation and i think the human humans
are not given enough credit to solve
some of these problems
um you know whether you believe in
climate change or not
um
you you still you know should be you
know we clean energy
makes some sense just as if you want
cleaner cleaner air and clean water it's
as clean as it's been in a long time ben
shapiro makes this point he says all of
these charts talking about the future
due to climate change don't take into
account mitigation efforts yeah or
innovation or innovation yeah the
changes that come like the famous story
of uh they said at the turn of the
century 1900's new york was going to be
covered in mountains of horse crap
because there's too many horses too many
people what are we going to do in the
car gets invented now there's no horse i
think if you're the guy that had the
buggy whip factory i mean your life was
good until all sudden it wasn't you know
and and i and i look at some of these
and that's why we need to make sure
that we're not i mean we're always
fighting the last war we're always you
know trying to win the last election
um and i think on some of this we're
we're not
we're not really believing in
the ability of human beings to solve
these problems
uh i mean because if we figure out a way
or if someone figures out a way to for
example
uh you know burn hydrogen uh and all of
a sudden you know the output of that is
is um water i mean you know that's i
mean those technologies are coming on
and cars already produce water yeah it's
exhausted right and so
i i don't know i i just i really think
uh you know i look at the iphone and
what the revolution of technology in my
life i mean i'm sure i think nobody here
except me probably had an answering
machine oh
you got home and you were excited
because it said two or it was blinking
and you pushed it and you listened to
the calls that it came in since you had
left i mean it was just it was just it's
and now i mean you can't like 24 7
speaking oh never mind yeah there's this
thing
i want to ask you about uh your time as
a.g though yeah
no no it's fine i mean when you were
there i mean i know you weren't there
for a long time did you see anything i
mean obviously russiagate was bunk
didn't you have the ability to look into
it to investigate dig into it yeah so so
i supervised the mueller investigation
and i'll never forget and i've talked
about this before
in fact i wrote a book above the law if
anybody wants to it's available on
amazon um
and what i talk about uh i don't think i
mentioned a lot in this book but but i i
know i i remember this like it was
yesterday because it was so impactful
is um you know there was a there was a
lot of controversy when i got appointed
uh i had been on cnn as a commentator
before i came to the department of
justice and for like four months they
hired me to you know sort of be the
conservative commentator and
you know one of the things i had said
which was very true which is i could
imagine
that uh the president trump would
appoint somebody new that would come in
and and had control of the budget of
mueller and would reduce the budget
there by limiting you know his ability
and his scope and and all that and you
know and i said that just as a
commentator
don't plan to do it but then you know
sort of everybody lost their mind when i
got you know became the supervisor of
the mueller investigation it's like i
almost looked prophetic like i had
planned
literally just you know but is that what
you did you reduced the budget or what
no i didn't do anything but but i had to
go through a ethics
review
um you know with with the most senior
career
doj official
who
actually it was because of the way it's
written it was my decision on whether i
just you know i could consult him but it
was my decision ultimately and he i
didn't ask him to write a recommendation
of course he wrote a recommendation
which says you know i should have
recused because of these these things i
said on cnn and i was just like this is
nonsense i you know i've i was a us
attorney for five and a half years i
know what it's like to be independent
and look at facts and apply the law and
make decisions and you know kind of my
my commentary as a paid cnn analyst is
not going to affect how i do this job
and you know it's just it wasn't even
apples for apples but anyway so you know
fast forward i clear that hurdle and i
get read into the mueller investigation
and you know the first thing they say is
you know what matt we have
they have not found any evidence of any
connection there's no evidence of any
connection between the russian
government and trump campaign
and i thought to myself well
why do we have this investigation
and so then i then
you know there were several other pieces
and parts and you know one of the things
that i read into for example was the um
roger stone investigation you know there
were several other components of this
investigation that that i was also read
into and you know given a status update
on
but
you know at that point in time you have
a decision to make and you know i mean
it life is all about you know sort of
replaying did you make the right
decision to make the right decision but
the decision ultimately and if you think
about how the regulations played out
if i wanted to fire bob mueller or end
his investigation
he
had they had to be for cause and so that
was a that was a big hurdle
and you also think about um you know
doing justice is it better for donald
trump to have a full report from mueller
saying there was no connection
or have matt whitaker acting attorney
general shut it down because there's no
point by trump yeah i mean and so you
you it just it it
you know i
the two things you know that
that in retrospect i now believe is that
you know sort of the the mueller
investigation was a total hit job by
anti-trumpers
it's i mean it is literally the january
6 committee but inside the department of
justice well what about ukraine as well
same thing
yeah
that was just the the train got rolling
before they realized what the evidence
was and then they kind of were you know
i mean this nancy pelosi hates donald
trump and she had the power to get
enough votes to file articles of
impeachment and improve them out of the
house full stop i mean that that's why
it happened
and i'm sure if nancy was here and was
honest um
and not dealing with her husband's you
know legal issues
i think she would say
i cannot believe
you know how tough donald trump is
how you know how hard how hard he fought
how how good his defense was and how you
know he kept the republican party you
know solid and you know supporting him
through those you know those
impeachments half the republican party
maybe yeah i don't i mean you lost i
think they feigned support i think a lot
of these guys they feign support i mean
all right name names of like who feigned
support lindsey graham
he comes out like he comes out on tv
that's talking about how he's all in
favor of trump but come on you see him
go you know walking down on the floor
and he gives kamala harris a fist bomb
he's not he's not really behind the
president you look at
you have uh in 2016 and 2018 the
republicans the public republican party
entertained and allowed the russia gate
nonsense to persist yeah they could i
mean you make a good point although i
mean i think you know i think cash and
devin i think we're you know we're
trying to get to the bottom of it i mean
it was just great there was
the i think the thing that we all forget
was just how much smoke
created
by the fbi and by you know sort of the
left and the clinton came in how much
smoke there was you had to you couldn't
see through it
because you just every time you'd like
run into something you'd be like oh
that's i mean maybe you know i thought
this was
it just it was it was a shiny object in
smoke and you just it was very hard to
get to the bottom and you know there
were a lot of people that didn't want to
get to the bottom of it because they
wanted that smoke there they wanted to
hamstring donald trump and the question
you know that i come back to tim and i'm
sorry i know this is your show so i
don't want to dominate the time
but what are you here for man what what
is so dangerous about donald trump why
do people want to take him down
so enthusiastically well i got some
ideas it could be that uh
back in 2009 it was i should say in 2012
it was reported in 2009 the cia had
reported they wanted to overthrow this
uh
bashar al-assad the assad family in
syria because they were trying to build
an oil pipeline to cut a turkey pipeline
up into europe to offset the russian
gazprom monopoly and uh syria explicitly
told the united states we're going to
support our ally russia not allowed to
build this in fact we're going to get
iran to tap the same gas field send it
up through iraq so we can basically
steal the oil and then we can control
oil prices into europe screwing with
your allies and so then conveniently for
the u.s there was a civil war in syria
the arab spring occurs and uh
we'll just throw it to we'll
fast-forward a little bit to ukraine in
which gazprom controls a large portion
the largest i believe of natural gas
flowing into europe through there now
that the nordstrom pipeline isn't coming
from russia and all of a sudden you get
this conflict in the euro maidan
movement where
ukraine wants to either join the joint
nato join the eu join nato join the west
or side with russia on their trade
federation and that's all happening
then donald trump comes in and he says
we're getting our troops out of the
middle east well that's bad news if you
dedicated 10 15 20 years to building
this pipeline and getting oil to your
allies in europe but what is donald
trump he gets elected what does he do he
gets elected and sure enough the
conflict in ukraine dies down simmers
down isis is getting crushed abraham
accords well that's big bad news if you
need the conflict to justify destroying
the country of syria to build an oil
pipe like our gas pipeline the qatar
turkey pipeline and now joe biden gets
elected and it's right back on track
exactly where we thought we'd be ukraine
war lights back up we got gazprom back
in the news germany feuding with russia
and you have donald trump who was
telling them the entire time to become
independent stop relying on russia now
that's probably surface level scratching
why they may be mad it's very for
foreign policy heavy you could also look
at domestic policy donald trump banning
critical race theory contracting
companies that engage in critical race
theory trainings couldn't contract with
the united states all of these things
just fly in the face of their agenda and
then you have the personal oh boy was
hillary clinton mad it was her turn so a
lot of reasons why they really really
hate donald trump yeah but boy i mean i
just we i've never seen i mean we've in
our history we've never seen a president
this persecuted um kennedy
although he wasn't persecuted in public
yeah they just decided behind the scenes
i believe that it was time i mean i
think that they whacked the guy i don't
know for sure but i mean there's just so
much evidence that it was
coordinated by whoever yeah i don't know
i know that um
pew research showed that the tr trump's
press coverage was five percent positive
five i believe obama's was 40 42 i
believe so here's obama the first thing
he does again in office is he orders a
drone strike blown up a village of women
and children he he commits extrajudicial
assassinations on american citizens but
the media can't stop
let's just say patting him on the back
for a family-friendly uh way to describe
it plus we're in the air trump comes in
and uh the one thing the one thing they
give him is when he fires missiles into
syria they're like this is it and i'm
like there it is
when he fi when he fires missiles on an
airport in syria all of a sudden the
media is like donald trump's
presidential moment oh yeah starting
wars that's what they love about them
but uh when the economy is booming what
do they do they lie cheat and they smear
every single thing the guy does it never
ends yeah we never were in the age of
like social media manipulation like we
are now so if if trump had exist been
president 30 years ago or someone like
it maybe there have been newspaper
articles but it would have been all a
lot of it behind the scenes because
that's all they had now it's social
media it's slander on the news and all
that crap so we're seeing it for the
first time yeah
yeah i just uh
the fact that he fights through it all
and is you know not only as popular as
he is
um so that's why but just like he's he
is
never tired i mean it's like he eats it
like a candy bar
uh
it's really it's extraordinary um
just never seen a force like this in my
life and you know i mean i i'm around
him a lot and get to spend a lot of time
with him and and i'm i
sometimes i'm surprised and just that
you know kid from ankeny iowa
gets these opportunities but i also know
that he's just like he's a no bs kind of
guy yep he doesn't worry you know
doesn't worry that you didn't go to yale
or you didn't go to harvard or you know
sort of doesn't in other ways
can you are you effective can you get
the job done do you speak clearly and
you know make commitments and live up to
those commitments is those you know it's
just the basic you know kind of what
you'd expect out of a guy
that's uh you know sort of built
buildings
i look at everything that's happened
over the past several years and what's
happening now with the january sex
committee and there is a malignancy in
this country that is gutting it from the
inside donald trump what do you do he
brought auto industry back to michigan
an investment of i think around 3
billion dollars he cuts out the tpp he
starts bringing manufacturing back to
the united states the best numbers of
our lives jim cramer says foreign policy
abraham accords peace in the middle east
starting to take form he's meeting with
north korea walking into the dmc with no
security you take a look at the stuff
that donald trump did and it's like wow
one of the greatest presidents i've ever
experienced you know i i i i'm reluctant
a little bit to say the greatest
president uh one of the greatest
presidents i've said that before but i'm
like okay i get it i wasn't alive for a
bunch of the other presidents but in my
lifetime
the foreign policy actions
not perfect but really good no new wars
getting our troops out of the middle
east trying to make peace with north
korea shoring up our borders getting rid
of the tpp bringing manufacturing back
i'm just like wow all that stuff was
really good for us and then you take a
look at the democrats and everything
they're doing now and it is gutting and
ripping this country apart and it's
because of people like nancy pelosi
nancy pelosi who we know is enriching
herself off of her position that somehow
she just makes these excellent excellent
stock decisions that everybody's a heck
of a stock picker oh yeah yeah and then
people make a social media account
tracking her stock decisions it gets
banned yep you know you look at the
level of corruption the lies the
cheating the stealing and it just makes
me sick and the worst thing about it is
where is anyone to do anything about it
yeah and tim you might be onto something
here because i was just as you were
talking about all that it struck me
recently
that um
donald trump like you said had kind of
brought peace to the middle east and was
disengaging the u.s
from the need for middle eastern energy
and what does joe biden do and he's
going right back there exactly and
re-engaging in the middle east with the
saudis and you know
you know he obviously went to israel i
mean i don't know when i was there last
week
they were talking about uh how i guess
he drove into the west bank or gaza one
he went into one of the occupied
territories i hate using their
terminology yeah biden did and he took
off the israeli flag because he was
flying an american flag in israeli flag
but they took off the israeli flag
before he entered um the
i mean i think what do you call that
like the the part of israel that
is
palestine
it's not palestine i don't know who you
ask yeah it really it's that area is so
interesting to me and having been there
now and seeing it with my own eyes that
is a
fascinating uh you know history and it's
a current like real politic issue um
it's just i think gaza you're talking
about gaza the west yeah well so i guess
we can call them gaza and the west bank
i don't want to call them occupied
territories because they're not occupied
they're part of israel
um but anyway
you take a look at what big tech is
doing you take a look at how democrats
actively support a lot of what they're
doing you take a look at the cult
ideology gender ideology critical race
theory etc and these things just serve
to erode and destroy the united states
you don't see these things in china you
don't see these things in india you
don't see them in as you see them
somewhat in europe but in the united
states it is profound bill maher brought
it up i mean you look at the stuff with
what that's happening with uh kids
getting uh sex change operations this is
happening predominantly in in hyper
liberal areas and not in conservative
but it's not happening in other
countries you take a look at tick-tock
for instance
the things on tick-tock the overt
wokeness allowed we got banned from
tick-tock we really don't know why it
may have been because we had alex jones
on the show in china they don't allow
the woke stuff
because they know it's it will it will
erode the base of your country but
united states that's that is the law
that is what you have to abide by in
social media
it's almost the more destructive the
technology is for society the more it is
you know encouraged to be used and and
uh and prolific it's it's really
extraordinary um you know big tech
is i think going to get its reckoning
here in the next uh you know year to
three um
they've been given tremendous powers and
they have not they've abused those
powers we rag on republicans quite a bit
because they don't do a whole lot but i
will say from 16 2016 to 2018
you know maybe they just didn't realize
the extent to which things were
occurring when they were occurring the
way they were
then they lost in 2018 to the democrats
and they gained back some seats in 2020
but not enough for the majority maybe
come november we're uh three three and a
half months away about
maybe then the republicans will get the
house in the senate maybe we'll start to
see some subpoenas i want to see this i
want to see joe biden impeached for the
ukraine scandal joe biden engaged in an
overt quid pro quo uh uh it's it's
remarkable remarkable that that that
that donald trump could discover this
seemingly bumbling upon it and when he
asks the ukrainian president you look
into what that was about they impeach
him for it
because they knew joe biden was their
guy
a made man would get away with with the
crimes he committed going to ukraine and
saying i am going to deny a billion
dollar loan guarantee illegally even
though congress approved it because i
can do whatever i want unless you fire
the prosecutor by the way the prosecutor
happened to him to happen to be
investigating a company called barisma
where his son worked but that's besides
the point according to the media someone
was on the board of barisma yeah 83 000
a month and victor shoken was
investigating that and joe biden uh went
to the president said fire him or you're
not getting the billion dollars and the
president said you can't do that and joe
biden said call the president see what
he says well sob guy gets fired that guy
needs to be impeached over that we need
a congressional investigation we need a
select committee we need an
investigation on the 529 insurrection
when they threw a fight when they set
fire to the st john's church in the
guard post force the president into a
bunker i expect to see subpoenas of all
of the biden administration officials i
expect to see subpoenas contempt of
congress everything they can do if they
win and you know that's what worries me
because it sounds too good to be true
but but
do you think merrick garland and the
department of justice is going to
receive those
referrals
of course uh as enthusiastically as he
did the one with you know for bannon and
navarro and and of course i mean the
embarrassment that they did to peter
navarro i i still this
you know i was i was
my god this swearing thing is really
i'm sorry i was upset i feel like i was
very very upset
um
that the way that the the way roger
stone was taken down i thought that was
ridiculous
in fact you know i was the acting
attorney general at the time and i let
you know chris wray know
uh you know uh that that was not
acceptable that that was that was
clearly intentional middle finger cnn
was top tipped off but you don't need to
go i mean i understand officer safety
but we're talking roger stone is not
done anything about it yet
well what i mean you know you can you
can get the explanation yeah um but you
know sort of up operationally
i don't think we want attorney general's
attorney's general involved in
how to arrest someone they're going to
arrest or how you're going to execute a
search warrant i mean that's you know
that's you leave that to the people that
are doing the job this is the issue but
the democrats get in and think the exact
opposite of the way you think they say
light them up burn them down right i
know and then and you see that example
navarro being pulled off a plane uh
shackles you know if you believe peter
yeah he was you know his feet were his
legs were shackled i mean this is nons
this is absolute nonsense i mean he
should have been given a notice to
appear
right it's a misdemeanor remember
contempt of congress is a misdemeanor so
bannon was convicted of a misdemeanor
navarro is charged with a misdemeanor
we've never i mean that's the same and
and again i i'm just telling you that's
the same as like if you get a ticket
in a
national park i mean it's like it's the
same docket that you see in that case
it's what what is it two month minimum
uh in sentencing guidelines up to two
years
it's up to one year missing
under a year yeah oh right to you
because he's charged with two yeah yeah
yeah so that is like on par with like um
what driving on a suspended license
yeah i mean it's federal so it's a
little different uh you can't really the
the state you know state each state has
a different thing i mean i know you know
my experience in iowa having you know
defended
i mean
you would do you wouldn't you wouldn't
go to court on a misdemeanor you
wouldn't have a trial and a misdemeanor
typically i mean that's that's why the
case that's what the case was so fast
right and banis i mean it's like you
know it's just a there were two
witnesses and it's just yeah i mean he
didn't call any and the jury was out for
three hours and but of course waited for
their free lunch right um
how how long do you think they're going
to send sentences
did they sentence him yet
30 days or less i'm guessing he might he
might just get the you know i mean he
could get probation yeah
it is um
this is going to be
i hope this isn't controversial but you
know congress has a jail in the capital
and they're starting if they really
wanted to enforce their subpoenas they
would send their sergeant arms to go get
these people and put them in congress
jail and actually you know exert some
like you know some instead of offloading
it to the department of justice
and making it you know again making it
appear to be something much larger than
it actually is
i want to see
republicans win in november in uh the
house and the senate but i don't want to
see your typical republicans win i want
to see people like marjorie taylor
greenwin you know she's considered
controversial the media smears her left
and right she's got certainly views that
i don't agree with i don't care she's
fearless and she's she's fighting
against this stuff she's going to
congress and forcing these people to do
their jobs much like trump was that's
why people like trump that's why why
people like marjorie that's why people
like thomas massey or rand paul but they
also like people that fight
and they they want people that stand up
to the just the bs of washington dc that
don't like want to get invited to the
you know white wine cocktail parties
where everybody stands around with a
drink and chortles about conservatives
and you know they want people that sort
of actually are unwilling to play the
game
that are going to go to washington dc
and they're going to fight for what they
you know yeah that they fight for what
they got elected on and i mean you see
you have to be in tremendous
uh self-confidence to survive that i'll
i'll tell you uh i'll give you a good
example of i think the issue the left
and the right uh of the left and the
right
there was a
a guy who worked a taco bell and he had
a mask on it said black lives matter
and his bosses went to him and said you
can't wear that political stuff while
you're working here and he says i'm not
taking it off and i said if you don't
take that mask off we're going to tell
you to leave you can't work while you
have it on it says fine he goes outside
he films himself and says they wouldn't
let me wear this the activists attacked
a taco bell until taco bell issued a
statement saying you can wear black
lives matter stuff conservatives don't
do anything like that they say well but
if i
do that i'll lose my job it's like
you're right the left doesn't care when
they lose their job and you can argue
well because they don't have kids and
stuff fair point i'm just saying when
the left is willing to go to roger
stone's house at five in the morning
with cnn being tipped off and they bring
him out this way and the right is
unwilling to do anything about it or
push back in an equal or or opposing way
then you will get this indefinitely it
you know it's remarkable to me that what
happened to roger stone happened while
you were the acting agent
i i mean listen i i i take
responsibility for it it was under my
watch i was in charge of the department
of justice at the time um you know i
mean i
raised holy hell as best i could
but you know i just don't you know this
is philosophically
the best you can do is know that it
shouldn't and won't happen the next time
because it does
well i mean you know it does and it
doesn't i mean you know so at least
while i was there we didn't have
anything like that
go down
um but you know this is where
we have to um
have a higher standard for all
no matter what party you are for all
public servants we have to have a higher
standard
we can't just have our public servants
be
like everybody else
and hold them to the same standard
because it's going to end up you know as
it's going to
be just a complete
well you're right blank show see you
guys are killing me the cluster you're
right but here's the here's the issue
thank you right now you have
these young progressive personalities on
youtube whatever claiming republicans
are steamrolling everything and why do
they believe that because they think
they should get universal health care
but those republicans just won't let
them
meanwhile republicans are actually
compromising on everything on most
things uh gun control being the perfect
example
when the democrats on the left argue
that republicans are the roadblock
because they're only giving you a little
bit meanwhile the democrats are
arresting
former administration officials which is
like the red flag of all red flags in
terms of governmental collapse in crisis
the right being unwilling to do anything
or saying you know what we're going to
stand on decorum it's like
congratulations stand on your decorum
when they come and shackle your feet let
me know and i'll salute you as you go to
the gulag that's that's what's happening
no and i'm not saying that th that the
the right should you you know
unilaterally disarm
uh in fact it's quite the opposite you
know we gotta play the same game they're
playing uh we need to know the game
we're playing and then play it well but
this does not end up well um yeah i
don't you know if we if we just keep
smacking each other uh that's not good
for the american people and that's why
the voters
ultimately you know need to get
the right people i mean i i and throw
the ones out that they don't that aren't
working and we need to have we need to
have more primaries we need to have more
you know contested elections and and and
it needs to be from the bottom to the
top and it's just you know for me
um you know we can't um
you know
we all
learn
as we go and we you know we all adapt
and adjust and i just don't think
republicans are learning as well
as democrats right now let me ask you
about what happened with lee zeldin
so you have this guy with uh cat ears
you know i wouldn't call it uh people
are referring to as a bladed weapon is
that fair to say do you think would you
so it's a self-defense device
but i mean it it is you know it would if
if he had hit his you know
neck or artery or something he could
have bled out i mean there's there's no
doubt this is a very dangerous
situation um i you see this stuff and it
happened what a couple months
a couple months ago we just saw some guy
try to assassinate kavanaugh or at least
made great strides to get to that point
yeah no i mean again i i think i think
this this you know
culture of violence that we have right
now
uh and it's you know it's very broad um
but you know the political violence i
mean it's just incredibly dangerous is
this and it's you know is it is it you
know we talked about earlier is it is it
gonna be worth doing these jobs you know
even being a public figure i mean it's
just it's not
um it will be if you're a communist
if you're if you're in a cult or you're
ideologically driven like i just
mentioned this guy he's wearing the
black lives matter mask at taco bell and
he says fire me i'm not taking it off
he's willing to throw himself
you know on top of the of the issue
because he he'll sacrifice his position
to wear that mask and they give it to
him because of it and so you look at now
what's going on with
the violence
you've got people on the left who are
willing to destroy their careers or get
paid almost nothing to be in that
position and the right's unwilling to do
it they're saying things like you know
what it's easier and more comfortable
just to get out of here and do something
else and that's why they lose so now you
see this guy who attacked zeldin and he
says
he i guess the latest report is that he
didn't know who zeldin was or whatever
okay yeah i don't think you go to a
political rally the day after the day uh
the governor puts out a statement about
the guy getting up on stage holding a
weapon and then trying to and telling
him he's done and then moving gesturing
i'm being very careful here towards his
neck with it whether it's for the
microphones neck whatever
i don't i don't think you just do that
randomly
but these are people who when when you
get someone who's willing to sacrifice
their their livelihood and their job or
their own safety these are people who
are willing to wear all black and
firebomb federal buildings
uh i i gotta tell you man this is
asymmetrical uh culture war where the
right is like we're gonna win when
regular people wake up to the gas prices
and it's like yeah i think
that's that's that's potentially true a
lot of people working class families are
going to be looking at the five dollars
a gallon gas in the fort it's four
dollars and 30 cents average right now
and they're going to be very angry about
it but how many people are indoctrinated
and don't care about gas at all how many
posts have you seen on facebook where
people say
i don't care about high gas prices
january 6 is more important because i
see those all the time i see people who
are your facebook friends well i've got
thousands of people on
cleanse that list of crazy people even
biden said it's worth it so we could
stick take a stand for ukraine we did
the right thing
republicans
they were up before that even happened
don't want to sacrifice anything
and the left will sacrifice themselves
well they don't want to sacrifice they
have a lot to say i mean
you know
a lot of republicans are very successful
or and have you know have ambition i
mean they have goals and desires and you
know want to accomplish things not only
for themselves but for their family and
they want their family to be successful
so i i mean i hear what you're saying
you know
there's there's so many of these people
especially people uh many many
republicans retiring they don't want to
be involved in it at all so they're like
i'm going to retire yeah because it's
not worth the money maybe you made
enough money it is it would be so easy
for so many of these people you don't
need that much money to retire forever
and so what i see is what is the number
to retire forever yeah i mean let's just
look at the average retirement if you
wanted to be a regular person and you
retire on half a million to a million
now most of these people in congress i
think what is like half of them are
millionaires or some ridiculous number
so wouldn't surprise me i mean their
retirement benefits are also very good
right nancy pelosi's net worth is 135
million she could leave at any moment
she never has to work a day in her life
you've just got two fridges full of ice
cream by the way really expensive ice
cream too yeah these are people who just
want power yeah she she made a video
during the pandemic where like people
were hurting and broke and she's like
look at my 50 dollar i tried that's very
good and everybody was like thanks so
disgusting
oh yeah that's nancy pelosi for you
what's even more disgusting is tim doing
nancy pelosi i tried even
sides of the back your tongue smacking
on your inner cheek the the way i see it
man is um
i get it
i get it yeah you know look we we here
at tim cast we're successful
you know so here it would be so easy for
me i wish my podcast was successful
we've got a bunch of new shows we're
launching and and um i'm gonna break
down for everybody why we do what we do
um i think i mentioned this last week
timcast.com what was the first show that
we launched it was tales from the
inverted world true crime mystery
history podcast why they're very popular
particularly among women we already have
a political podcast where we talk ad
nauseum about all of these issues then
we launched pop culture crisis with bret
dasavek we brought on mary morgan to
co-host it because that's not political
because the goal for the website isn't
just to
argue with people and say hey that thing
they're doing on tv is dumb and that
thing that they said in congress was
stupid it's like we got to change
culture we got to change it all but
here's the crazy thing
it is
people don't i don't think people
understand how difficult it is to do all
of this how much time it takes
16 hours a day plus you know several
hours on the weekends every waking
moment of my life on the phone answering
emails and i got to figure out which
emails to answer to make all of this
work and it would be so incredibly easy
to cut everything down do a single show
and just be wealth and say why am i
risking my neck and stressing myself out
for people who won't do the same
because i genuinely believe that there
are a lot of people who listen who do
want to do that and so maybe there are a
lot of people who are like you know
those all that cult stuff is really bad
but i'm not gonna i'm not gonna get
involved great well i'm not talking to
them i guess maybe i'm trying to
encourage them to stand up and change
the world but i think there are a lot of
people who are like
i'm ready i'm willing and i'm gonna
speak up and i'm gonna make a difference
and i'm like well then we gotta have a
space that allows for that to happen and
we got to encourage more and more people
to get involved so i'm i'm more content
doing that
as opposed to so many other people who
you know they're
i don't want to be in government because
it's not worth the pay and then the
democrats try to destroy you and then
you look at what they put brett
kavanaugh through so there's certainly a
lot of people who are standing up who
are pushing back and doing the right
thing and i can respect them and i think
we got to get more people to do it but
the way i see it with what we're doing
at tim cast is at the very least we're
just going to create a cultural space to
the best of our abilities we're going to
fight for it every day
to not just be overtly political because
one thing the right does and they they
do terribly is they argue about what the
left does instead of doing things they
say hollywood made a movie the movie
sucks okay well now you got the daily
wire making their own movies
teamcast.com we're starting to launch
our own shows that's the path
we create shows we create culture and we
create a new place for people to go to
get away from the influence of the
democrats and their psychotic cult
that i think is the path towards
changing things it is the hardest path
possibly to take so
i totally get it why there are so many
people who are like i make good money
why speak up yeah and in the in the
frightening thing i'm sure for you all
and i'm sure you know the reason you're
trying to get more at on your website
is because of how easy it is for big
tech to de-platform you
oh hands-down i mean it's just it's it's
because you know there there are
ways to monetize these types of things
that are you know that are pretty good
when you're on these platforms but they
can take it away tomorrow and that's i
mean that that's that's what anybody
that wants to create a show or content
or or do anything i mean you don't do
obviously you don't do it for the money
but like that i think that's a reward
for being good it's and it's not just
about uh like getting banned it's about
the manipulation the shadow banning yeah
so you know we we had a show called cast
castle which was like a vlog and we did
bits and then we ramped up the joke
because honestly just it's fun to write
jokes and act um and then the issue is
we can't do a lot of jokes you get
banned for it or
you could build your business up on
their platform they don't ban you they
just cut your money off after a decade
of investment and then your show's gone
and it's like okay
why build up their platform we'll build
up ours and so now you know this show is
live on the front page of timcast.com
we're doing a lot we've done
infrastructure we've kicked paypal off
the website
paypal in their sensorius attitudes in
silicon valley cultism we now use
parallel economy which is co-founded by
dan bongino and is censorship resistant
so my view is hopefully in five years
the big pop culture conversation is oh
yeah that new movie just came out on
timcast.com and we're we're not going to
be overtly political we don't make
conservative content we're not
conservatives just make content then
it's not woke and we'll create a space
to call out the lies the democrats have
been pushing and look i don't like the
uniparty republicans either but the
democrats are the ones who control the
cultural institutions that are burning
everything down you're right you're
right
that's what we do i guess good i love it
that's why i'm here
yeah i heard good things well i'm i'm
i'm optimistic in that regard but i also
kind of feel like we're building an arc
in a sense like it's going to get way
worse than it is now a lot of people
think that's pessimistic i'm like i
don't look at it negatively you know i
just look at
i think i look at it like mathematically
what's happening now culturally
culturally and politically is
negative points towards the united
states it's getting worse it's getting
worse
that doesn't mean everyone's going to
die and the sun's going to burn out and
the plants no there's still a rome
they're still a rome there's no roman
empire well
i mean that's just like that it turned
into a church the roman catholic church
now
it's another kind of mental control they
couldn't do it militarily it was too big
it splintered so they just want to keep
keep that influence yeah and i think you
know
uh
my friend rick grinnell says often you
know most uh great civilizations have
lasted about 250 years we're what 246
right now we're there yeah and so we we
have the the people of the united states
are going to have to decide and uh i
think there are a lot of headwinds in
that regard i also think
you know we're the greatest idea ever
conceived in human history right so
we'll see if we can you know as a people
figure it out yeah i don't think it's
going to be through legislation i don't
think we can legislate solution or print
solutions within the federal reserve
it's it's industry like actually making
things like graphene like it's obsessive
we've been talking about the last two
years to bring awareness we have been
obsessively talking i thought i have i
have been but i don't even are you
familiar with the material it's now
graphing time oh oh oh uh check this out
check this out you know to ian's credit
i got an ad for an electric bike its
range was 150 miles
that blew my mind yeah because we've got
some electric bikes the range is like 40
or 50 miles and it charges in 15 minutes
it's incredible 15 minutes so this is a
battery compound it's a pure carbon it's
just carbon and it's hexagonally lattice
like a honeycomb flat one layer atomic
thick but it's electrically conductive
capacitive like a battery it's super you
can super conduct my point
the bike uses a graphene battery dude
and it's you can pull carbon dioxide out
of the air and put it on
condense it onto palladium and then turn
it into graphene so we can basically
mine the air mine the carbon out of the
air we can mine the methane out of the
air and we're gonna be end up competing
with trees so if we we just need to
renegotiate
and and bring awareness to the
government i think to teach them about
the 21st century industry well isn't
this the point i was trying to make
earlier and obviously you do it better
with like a real technology but it's but
human innovation is you know going
because that doesn't that solve the
excess carbon in the environment if
we're competing with trees trees are the
ones that are pulling out carbon dioxide
but this is what we're running into
because because yes right we get carbon
in the air and then like ian says we
mine the air for carbon and we need more
of it we can't take too much you run
into people who post things memes like
elon musk is wasting money going to
outer space that money should be spent
here in the in the united states and
it's like where do you think they spent
the money do you think that elon went to
the moon and gave moon people our money
no he hired american workers to work on
american products to machine american
parts to make an american spaceship it
goes up into space and then it comes
back
these people don't understand when we
talk about new technologies you are up
against ideology versus innovation and
the ideologues are saying there's too
much carbon therefore
shut everything down
take away people's fuel let the
diabetics die when the refrigerators
stop working they don't have insulin
anymore and that will solve the problem
and then you have the innovators saying
can we i don't know mine carbon from the
air to reduce the parts per million so
that we can offset global warming but
then also use it for something
innovative no they don't want to give
you the chance there are people who
oppose human ingenuity and people who
support it and right now the democratic
party
what are we watching right now joe biden
selling off 20 million barrels of the
strategic petroleum reserve a decent
amount goes to china they say the reason
is because china it legally has to go to
the highest bidder so europe and then
china they get it and my question is joe
biden if if if he comes which makes no
sense i want to just though
hang a lantern on what you just said
yeah which is true but
it makes no sense it's the united states
strategic patrol reserve
it's not supposed to be sold off it's
supposed to be used not to be but
they're trying they're trying to lower
the prices so the question is you know
if joe biden
comes out and says he's going to get us
off fossil fuels
and then you see i think jeremy where
they shut down their nuclear plants
right is that what happened i believe so
yes i think so you i don't know you want
to fact check that
they did
i'm wondering then you know they're not
greta tunberg says we don't want to wait
until 2030 we want to stop fossil fuels
now and it's like
it just sounds like they want to kill
people that's all it sounds like that
we've got a food shortage coming in they
say stop farming we've got a fuel crisis
and they're saying sell it off and shut
down our power plants and i'm like
you're just trying to get rid of humans
bill gates wrote four years ago we have
to stop poverty in africa because
they're having too many kids so there'll
be more poor people and i'm like
so you're not saying kill them you're
saying don't let them exist in the first
place
it sounds an awful lot like they're just
nuking the system on price i think a lot
of it is ignorance like maybe there are
some destructive people that want to
wipe out a segment of the population
just for whatever short-sighted
desire but the people that want to
create less carbon don't seem to
understand that we can pull it out of
the atmosphere pretty readily well
that's the point ideology versus
innovation how do you convince a zombie
horde screaming the end is nigh that
there are ways to solve these problems
to technology you can't there
you know i saw a video turning point usa
we had actually let me let me just let
me see if i could pull this up and we'll
talk about it we got this tweet from
turning point usa
they say yesterday the view and whoopi
goldberg smeared and lied about tp usa
uh regarding an incident where supposed
nazis showed up outside the the student
action summit basically they say oh
there were nazis there yeah there were
weirdos waving a flag outside the event
on the public sidewalk folded flags
freshly unfolded yeah yeah wonderful
probably probably the left it was yeah
the left created this story i mean then
whoopi goldberg says they were
pseudo-affair they were in there she's
forced to come back out and say they
weren't in there but they were uh they
weren't inside the building but you know
they were they were they were mixed in
with the people it's all big it's all
just outright lies
about everything
so oh so instead of the same person who
got in trouble for
what she say the holocaust wasn't
racially motivated yeah now let me play
this book
let me play this clip for you real quick
and um avert your ears children this may
be rather shrill and annoying you've
been warned
[Music]
this this young woman screaming
for literally no reason nothing she
understands how do you say to her ma'am
did you know that we can solve the
problem of climate change by mining
carbon from the atmosphere put it in a
song a hit song because that gets the
mindless zombies to dance along perhaps
ian write a hit song called we can mind
graphing from the air
and then these people will start
screaming and then you play the song
no the problem is they you know what i
think the zombie hordes hate they want
to hate they hate
and
it's like that you know that meme where
the guy says i'm angry and the guy says
here's a solution and then he burns and
says i don't want a solution i want to
be mad he's like i'm mad i want to be
mad
this woman's screaming and i got to tell
you i don't know her personally but i
will tell you my experience having been
at these protests there's no reasoning
with these people
none
of them not in the moment for sure but
no no no not just not at all i've been
there i've been to their act i've been
to their meetings
these and those are impossible in a room
with a bunch of people or like good luck
no no no i'm talking about what i'm
talking about possible the private rooms
on occupy wall street where they were
squatting inside one of the buildings
yeah same thing i wonder if we're at the
same meeting maybe awesome and
everyone's sitting down with in small
groups having conversations and these
people are zealots they don't care they
they you are dealing with ideology
versus logic and they don't yeah you
can't head on it you gotta subvert it
and kind of make them believe it without
them realizing they're believing it
which is why i put no no no no you
you misunderstand i agree with you on
that point but what i'm saying is
they want hatred yeah it's addictive and
so if you tell someone i got this really
good idea that we could mine carbon out
of the atmosphere to stop climate change
they would say
i don't care i hate these people i hate
these people hate is like real it's
something that they can like at least
they know they have control of something
as long as they can continue to when it
goes away then it's this
uncertainty that can lead to like terror
and so they snap back to what they know
that's kind of a natural phenomenon i
just i i was in
san bernardino
there was a group of people protesting
holding up signs
and they had all stopped and they were
talking to each other and i walked up
and i was like how's it going guys and
they just looked at me like some of them
like oh hey what's up and i was like i
just wanted to ask you guys like what's
going on like what are you what are you
doing and then someone walks up and
starts screaming mike jack mike jack
mike check
instantly all of the activists start
repeating in unison mic check that's
what you're supposed to do what what
does that even mean i don't know what
michael like this mic mic check is a
technique that the activists the cults
use to uh
they claim bring them back to the truth
amplify voices when you can't hear
things freaky weird oh is that where
they repeat like
oh my goodness
i went to occupy i wouldn't do it i
refused i just screamed as loud as i
could so they didn't have to repeat me
because it was so called it was called
it's a cult it's a call it gets you to
repeat the thing they make you repeat it
several times and so when i tried
talking to people they immediately start
yelling mic check stopping the
conversation and the woman said she goes
do not and they all go do not and she
goes talk to anyone and they'll repeat
talk to anyone they are trying they are
trying to trick you to trick you and
then she says it again and they all just
mindlessly chance you don't get it man
like i hear what you're saying about
subverting and like trying to convince
them but when people are in a zombie
horde controlled by a zombie lord
i don't know what to tell you because
i've been in private with them and they
have cognitive dissonance and they
experience physical pain when you
provide information that could shatter
that and when they're in public they're
unwilling or just so angry look at this
woman she's screaming at drew
hernandez's face for no reason she
doesn't know him know anything about him
and she's saying stand up fight back
what does that mean i want the context
what did drew say do you have is there
more of the video oh i don't have it but
but come on like
no we don't need context i must know the
humanity in the woman you will
what is your name what does stand up
fight back mean
okay what are they what are the rhetoric
what are they what are they protesting i
don't know what is it twitter free
isabel
they're amoral and they want to cling to
something that feels like a moral system
zombies
what makes someone susceptible to that
you know i i
why is it not you
why is it not me i don't know like why
isn't it like not any of us these crowds
yeah um
strong mental fortitude and independent
having a job i don't know about that
um
i think it's i think it's uh
i don't know if it's
nature or nurture
because i wonder
how is it that throughout my life i have
been fiercely independent maybe it's
maybe it's uh nurture you know the way i
was raised are you scottish by chance
no uh part irish okay that might explain
it but uh i'm a bunch of different
things
growing up in on the south side it was
like
you know figure it out it's all you know
maybe that's it maybe maybe these are
kids who had everything handed to them
and they have no idea to solve their
problems i think that could be a big
part of it because there are so many
people who say i don't know what to do
and i'm like i gotta be honest if you
are an adult and you don't know what to
do to be successful then
you prop you did not have parents who
taught you the things you needed to do
to survive or circumstances that did
because i was lucky enough to have a bit
of both i had uh parents who basically
hey get out of the house and go do stuff
and so forcing me to be more independent
that was what we did back then when i
was a kid we be we'd be anti-grounded my
parents would be like get out of the
house like you're sitting inside too
much go do something come back when the
street lights turn on that was that was
me growing up and so
solve your problems you're right i got
uh
we had a house
uh that didn't have a deck off the
sliding glass door
my parents just never put one on there
and they if there's one now there
they're still in the same house but they
um my mom would just open up that
sliding glass window and yell and
whistle the same way she would call the
dog
uh that was when it was time to come in
for dinner
you know like most of our childhoods it
was like that was just normal i would i
remember i was like i'm like 14 and my
friends were all jumping on the freight
trains and riding them because you know
our area was like from where we lived
where the park was like three miles so
you'd be walking down the tracks you'd
hear the thing the trains going like 15
or 20 miles an hour you run and then
just grab and hang on and it brings you
all the way there is there were little
kids doing this stuff yeah
just figure it out on your own i wonder
if these kids don't have that well this
girl
i watched her eyes when she was
screaming it looks like some sort of
amphetamine intercept like it looks like
a federal yeah adderall maybe because
like the eyes are so
round and pupiled and they're not
matching with the mouth
i think kids that like are on drugs
at age 12 13 14 even younger
don't know
how to be happy really or they don't
know what they're protesting yeah they
don't they don't have like a solid
formation of what they think reality is
without the drug right so there were
protesters today outside the uh marriott
marquis oh yeah how is this
yeah i'm used to it um and i hate to i
hate to say i have one
one rule of protesters
um please write your signs so they can
be read
at about 35 miles an hour because for
some reason jeff sessions when i was uh
worked with him
um
had a lot of people that didn't like him
and had a lot of protesters would show
up everywhere we went around the country
and these people would write these very
convoluted signs that didn't make any
sense i mean there were a couple like
two-word ones like fu like that that
made sense i get your perspective but
remember when someone made a sign that
said rahm emanuel likes nickelback how
dare they and then all of a sudden
everyone started writing similar signs
yeah and became a meme because these
people aren't prosperous game day's the
best for that they're not protesting
anything they're showing up and trying
to just be part of a crowd to feel
included or something they need to go to
church
right well they don't have this is their
church right yeah that's it which is so
trite to say but it's true it is and so
the funny thing is how
i take a look at this right um i'm
certainly not christian by any standard
i take a look at this and i take a look
at it there's always time well i would i
was when i was younger i went to
catholic school and uh i was raised
catholic and then i believe in god but i
don't believe in any of the uh organized
religions for the most part um so you're
spiritual no that's
not spiritual yeah he is
do you believe in a power greater than
yourself yes okay
um
i think logic you pray
i i i think maybe christians would
i don't consider it praying in the same
way that a christian would or someone
else so maybe maybe not i wouldn't say
so but uh when i when i stand back and i
see modern christianity i see some
people who believe stupid things i see
some people who think there's a giant
man in a row bald in the clouds who's
watching over us which is silly but then
i see people who are um
more uh learned when it comes to
philosophy and theology and they
actually question and they have um
legitimate reasons for believing the
things they do
but more importantly i say okay let's
talk about the general outcome of what
we have were there bad things before uh
modernization and reformation oh you
betcha and there still are a lot of
religions but i tell you this when i go
down
i was hanging out with sheamus who's a
catholic and we went down to uh
charlestown after after we met up with
him after mass got out i see a bunch of
little kids playing wearing nice clothes
with their parents and their parents are
keeping their kids safe and they're
sharing food with the needy and things
like that i'm like all those things are
really good you want to have a gathering
and your idea of doing right by your
community is teaching your kids to be
good people and providing food to the
needy i'm like dig it really great
if your idea of a gathering and
community building is screaming at the
top of your lungs and throwing bricks
and harassing people we got a very
serious problem with your moral
framework so what do we see right now
perhaps there will be a reformation of
leftist ideology in 2000 years and
they'll realize that maybe they should
actually practice what they preach and
instead of screaming in people's faces
and throwing bricks at them they give
them bread a lot of these people do that
when i see people doing like foods not
bombs giving out food i've seen this in
my entire life that's fantastic if
that's your idea of organizing that's
great
and then of course there you know
historically there have been you know
bad christians as well modern times
right now i'm not going to sit here and
complain about the 50s
you know those times have passed civil
rights won congratulations my family's
certainly happy that it happened now i'm
looking at
your average christian and um
maybe not doing enough to raise their
kids properly and so this is why you're
seeing a wave of young people
becoming dejected and lost
but i see at these universities some new
kind of pseudo-non-theistic religion in
critical theory wokeness
i don't think any of these one terms
defines what's happening uh they say
intersectional feminism they say
wokeness they say critical race theory
critical gender theory critical theory
none of those things actually explain
what we're seeing the emergence of a
non-theistic religion perhaps woke-ism
is the best all-encompassing term these
are people who have all of the similar
traits of a newly formed religion or
dogma they are violent they are angry
they have no rhyme or reason or logic
behind what they do is this
transhumanism do you think this is a
transhumanistic religion no it's almost
like um the way i explained it before is
i read a physics book about uh when they
captured electrons in a two-dimensional
plane and simulated a an element
so an element for instance has got like
a hydrogen has an atomic weight of one i
believe yeah one proton one proton with
an electron
orbiting it so what i read was that in a
two-dimensional plane they captured an
electron in simulated orbit there was no
proton nucleus but it adopted the
properties of hydrogen because of the
confined space and the forced movement
of the electron or whatever and so they
injected an electron another one into it
and it simulated helium effectively but
there was no core there was no nucleus
and that's what i see here i see
the all of the bad of religion amassed
into one group with no rhyme or reason
or dictating principles just chaos it is
like a fire consuming burning full of
rage and there's no reasoning with it
yeah you do it's like
so they're forcing it's not happening
natural it's like it's like a forced um
creation as opposed to happening
naturally
it's like take take a bunch of people
it's it's you know what it is it's
really simple it's uh
take a christian society which the
united states absolutely is and and the
left might be like no we're not i'm not
saying it should be i'm saying that the
overwhelming majority of people in this
country identify as christians and
historically have done so and then what
you do is over time
those kids
the next generations next generations
slowly cease to hold the values
and what you end up with is all that all
of the elements of dogma without any of
the moral framework yeah like when you
tell yourself i i have to go do this
thing because that's what a christian
would do or i have to go yell at a crowd
because that's what a true believer
would do you're the electron without the
core
it comes nat you don't need to be told
what to do to get it done you know it's
it's inherent in the system if you look
around and you're open to it but that
requires
some sort of i don't know stability you
know it's crazy
the the lady from the westboro baptist
church who got de-radicalized on twitter
you know the story oh yeah i can't
remember her name but she was on her
yeah she was on twitter and then people
started having conversations with her
and then she was like wow okay maybe i'm
wrong about this uh daryl davis talking
about how he met with klansmen and then
he's a black man and he talks to him and
then they turn in their robes and say i
don't want to do this anymore. and then
you take a look at these people and
they're the complete opposite there's no
reasoning they're just screaming and
dogmatic i think it was megan phelps
roper is the woman that left the
westboro baptist church yeah yep
that was a rogan interview that was
pretty cool i believe
yeah
i wonder what this uh you know watching
this video from from uh uh it's uh front
lines with drew hernandez seeing this
video of this woman just screaming and
it's just so uh it's it's exactly what i
experienced for a decade i'm like where
did these people end up i keep thinking
of like the second coming of christ and
like how they say in the apocalypse or
the end times that christ will re-emerge
to unify the planet or whatever i don't
know maybe you know more about it i
don't know but that maybe that's what we
need right now with like obviously islam
and christianity but now this too yeah
well i mean you know obviously
christians including myself believe that
jesus will come again he promised he
would
um you know there's some belief that
he'll come through the east gate on the
temple mount i was just there
a week ago he was not there at the time
he hasn't been there yet um
well he clearly didn't come to unify as
he said himself
um a lot of us you know are human nature
and human you know just failing i mean
we you know we always
human beings for the you know through to
time and memorium have always you know
sort of um put themselves at the center
of the universe i mean this that's why
um i think these pictures from this new
um
uh
satellite
that that are bringing
you know 150 million years of you know
have been extraordinary but it just it
points just i mean not only how many
universes there are but just how like
how remote how many universes there are
well i'm not you know i'm sorry
multiverse theories galaxies no galaxies
thank you yeah
something though i misspoke but thank
you for stopping me they have actually
just channeled the truth i was like yeah
i think you're channeling the truth
there you know multiverse theory huh
well this is is
something that i've had deep
conversations with with smart people and
you know at the end of the day you know
physicists can't explain
where where what it's expanding into
and and it just gets really you know
been the curvatures and things bending
and donuts and all that and and i just i
think these pictures are just
extraordinary because if you look at the
like like a like the size of what was it
the size of like a a pin the head of a
pin and it had all of these galaxies in
it now you want to just it was just and
you just think like you know we're just
like on this random one arm
of one galaxy
uh kind of really sort of out of you
know outside of the middle of all that
it's just absolutely it blows your mind
sometimes there's a scary thing about it
though right the universe is expanding
like either yeah i totally agree i think
you're like freaking me out
like there's so much life in the u in
this universe i would imagine there's so
much of us here's a scary thing they say
the universe is expanding and it's
expanding faster right
so that means it looks like it there
will come to a point where
the universe has expanded so much when
you look into the night sky you will see
literally nothing because the light
because it's moving away from the light
that's moving away from us faster than
it can come to us
people
in that era
will think there is nothing else i think
that's an optical illusion because the
universe is twisting around on itself
you mentioned the donut the taurus and
that because it's because the wavelength
is turning it looks like it's changing
color uh it's called the red shift in
nature it looks and they say well that
means it's getting further away but it
might just be that the
the wave is bending and your it looks
like it's becoming a shorter frequency
or a longer frequency depending on how
it's bending
and um it's just twisting that
okay perhaps and perhaps we'll go to
super chats if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends if you like it
and head over to timcast.com become a
member we're gonna have that members
only show coming up at 11 p.m last night
we had zubi on that was a really great
conversation and of course you also want
to check out
if you're looking for something to do
while you're on a road trip or it's late
night you're trying to chill tales from
the inverted world these episodes we've
really cranked up the production value
and we're getting ready to relaunch cast
castle these are going to be 20 to 30
minute episodes it's going to be a whole
lot of fun with a whole lot of jokes and
more shows to come comedy specials all
that good stuff a lot of stuff we also
have
we are going to be launching the
inverted world podcast which is i know
tesla inverted world had a podcast audio
form
this is going to be shane cashman
actually taking calls and discussing the
creepy the paranormal the mysteries
hauntings
with uh people all over the country so
we're actually setting up a way that you
guys can submit your stories
tell them and then we're gonna be
creating a weekly show that's gonna
explore all of this stuff so that's all
to come
let's read some super chats
bree sullivan says is the death penalty
a deterrent for drug dealers aren't
there executions less refined than ours
who's whose executions
the drug dealers like the cartels
well yeah so so what do you think do you
think the death penalty deters crime
that's that's actually uh i i don't know
the the honest answers i don't know i
think
many
uh death penalty eligible crimes are
crimes of passion and i'm not sure
people consider
when they're you know killing another
human being that they're you know going
to be punished
at the same time
i think it also is like the
the society statement on
on the what the moral code is right
yeah
all right gk madison says do you know
about bill whittle in his plan to make a
star trek like open universe for
animated shows that aren't woke he's a
fan of yours and your efforts to make
entertainment fun again cool glad to
hear it thank you i didn't know that oh
you're finna yours i'm sorry this is
your this is your super chat yeah
talking about uh launching new shows
all right john smith says matt please
run against rhino joni ernst in 2026.
what are your political aspirations you
gonna run so i lost to joni in a primary
in 2014. um joni is uh is a friend of
mine obviously iowa is a very small
state so people that are active and
involved know each other
you know i don't have any immediate
desire to run for office i was there was
a lot of people that wanted me to run
this year
chuck grassley is our longtime u.s
senator
they wanted me to either primary him or
they wanted me to run you know for
attorney general and i just i've um i'm
happy with where i am i you know i've
offered myself to the iowa voters twice
now and uh have not been successful um
statewide and so i'm you know i'll i'll
look for opportunities for public
service you know maybe that's in the
next administration maybe that's
uh you know sort of doing my my thing
you know with my my show and uh you know
the other ways i don't know i mean i i
so as a believer you know
in god i think you know a lot of this is
part of god's plan and he's given me
certain um
abilities and talents and you know some
of those lend themselves to public
speaking and doing other things but at
the same time you know i'm very content
i don't need it and that's that's a
great place to be because i think when i
was a younger man i sort of needed um
you know i was very ambitious and i
needed that
um that victory because i'm you know
very competitive i played college
football and played sports growing up uh
but now i'm in a good place and uh you
know really am enjoying what i do now
but at the same time you know if the
president were to ask me to do something
i would certainly be very interested
well let's get this one crackerjack says
me and the wife were talking i wanted to
ask you if you think trump will truly
clean house like he says because we
still have our doubts after his last run
granted he was held back by democrats
trump said he wants to fire everybody
what do you think he's going to do it
yeah so i've i've been reading the news
reports too and and i think the this
president for
much of the administration was
um limited by a lot of the people he had
in place you know and some of those were
career a lot of them were his own
political appointees
and i think he is much smarter and much
keener on that he's trusting fewer
people he's not just you know he
understands that who the deputy attorney
general at the department of justice
matters
and you know so it's and it's all the
way down in every organization so yeah i
think he's a lot more attune is he going
to clean house
i think he's going to count a lot on
some key people to execute his plan uh
if trump he'll be a lot more effective
in the first two years than he was last
time yeah if he only ran one commercial
from now until election day where he
goes
ladies and gentlemen of america if you
elect me i'm gonna fire everybody have a
nice day i'd be like okay yeah you got
my vote
go for it
there's too many people in this in this
government we need to clean
clean up get the corruption out of there
drain the swamp fire the swamp monsters
whatever bring in new people that new
people really and our founding fathers
never intended
um
a public service to be a career yeah uh
they they thought it would be a
sacrifice that you had to
go away from you know ride a horse or a
train
initially a horse and then you know sort
of be inconvenienced and and and now
um it's just that we have these career
you know as politicians that all they've
ever done is politics all they've ever
done is be elected and it's it's not
good for the republic
so christina h with one of the most
important super chats i've ever read
what do you get when you cross an angry
sheep with an angry cow
two animals that are in a bad mood
that was too good i had to read that's
good that was too late
yeah we needed that that was good
i hope a bunch of people left for roll
their eyes
of the joke
all right joe burns says just got told
at my security job that we will be
enforcing a new mass commanding policy
within the county i plan to remind the
frustrated employees who think uh who uh
who to thank for this come november
yup
ant-man says drug dealers are turning
people into zombies look up the
kensington area of philadelphia to see
how bad things actually are people
shooting up in public and being unable
to function in society yo did you see
those videos
no when like the kids get off the bus
from school and there's like people
standing there and they're all like i
can't see that drunk yeah and they need
to walk through it yeah
horrible get out of cities man
i appreciate all of the 20s in chat for
the moo joke thank you christina that
was fantastic wholesome yes
all right
ramtak says should a.g garland recuse
himself from an investigation of trump i
doubt he will
should he
well he would have to do the same uh you
know analysis uh for you know whether or
not he has a conflict um
i you know i'm just off the top of my
head i can't think of anything but i
haven't really done i haven't thought
through the facts and circumstances
all right um he certainly should
recuse himself for hunter biden
i don't think there's any doubt about
that we should get a special prosecutor
yeah no that should there should be a
special counsel point there's i just
can't imagine a world where um the you
know but this is you know left does you
know if you remember this is a long
tradition of uh the democrats in control
of the department of justice never
taking
the political appointees out of
prosecution decisions they just won't do
it
all right greg cox says the government
the govern government supplied cartels
with weapons fast and furious and
shuttled drugs to inner cities freeway
ricky ross our government is broken
fundamentally trump says it constantly
why should we trust him on this as he is
part of the system
uh i think trump tries i think he tried
i think he made mistakes because he was
naive i think trump thought that if he
elected the president he'd be able to
get the job done because well he's the
president then he realized there's a
bureaucratic state that's gumming up the
works
and he figured it out too late i think
what the schedule f stuff happened in
2020 yeah it's like the last year he had
and he's like okay schedule left we're
gonna fire these people and then
try again next time we'll see
all right i'm not your buddy guy says
despite my support for the death penalty
my biggest issue is i can easily see
leftists using it on their political
opponents they really have lost it
regardless we should make asylums great
again
what does that mean
asylums for the for people who are
mentally ill lock them up
so they were counting i could get bad
real fast yeah they'll just lock you up
they'll be like you're a conservative
that's a mental illness lock them up
they were like notoriously bad in the
80s reagan like ended a lot of them and
put a lot of people onto the street yeah
supreme court also ruled that
essentially you can't um
detain people without you know kind of
just
for you know there was a fundamental
right to you know sort of be free and
not be detained
talking cover says please tell matt go
big red from a irl cornhusker fan he'll
get it being from iowa friendly rivalry
oh my goodness
everywhere i go i mean i'm telling
everywhere i go these nebraska fans are
always you know want to be representing
i don't think they've beat us in like
the last six or seven years what
position did you play that's a tight end
nice you're in the rose bowl right i
played in the rose bowl in 1991 and
did you were you blocking a lot or did
you play pass uh so i caught
this again the chat should be able to
look this up but i caught like 20 22
balls over the course of my career two
touchdowns um i had a good i had a good
time it's a great way to pay for school
all right we got one for you
greg cox says this guy was acting
attorney general does he not read the
filings that cross his desk didn't he
have access to the previous filings if
he disagreed why didn't he investigate
as a dod funds manager i kept all
paperwork for nine years to current does
the ag office not keep that standard
i i mean i did read everything across my
desk i
didn't retain my files i was i left um
on valentine's day of 2019 so i mean i
was you know i haven't
gone
they should all all the documents should
be there there's no doubt about that i
mean what can you do as a g i mean can
you launch investigations can you yeah i
mean there's there's a lot you can do
there's a lot you shouldn't do as well
but you know you need to have
your um you know finger on the pulse of
that institution and especially anything
that's um
that's important that's going to happen
you need to you know be fully briefed
and you know if necessary you have the
authority and responsibility to insert
yourself in it when trump gets elected
he should appoint marjorie taylor green
as attorney general
all right
can he do that is she a lawyer
no do you have to be um i'm pretty sure
to be the attorney general i would have
to look at you don't got to be a lawyer
to be a supreme court justice that's
true you have to be learned in the law
but you don't have to have a law degree
um i think to be attorney general you
have to be an attorney oh okay
who's a good lawyer so that's that would
be to go back
the justice department was formed um by
in the grant administration and i've had
the great fortune to go to the archives
and seeing
the document the original document
signed
the bill that was signed by grant
that was really cool
all right well then we'll have to find a
good lawyer
maybe uh maybe he'll do uh with jeffrey
clark cash patel yeah jeffrey clark oh
yeah cash yeah yeah is cash but cash was
doing something else what did he do he
was uh
he was he was started as a public
defender and then he became a terrorism
prosecutor no but what was what was he
appointed to in the church uh so he was
the dod chief of staff right he was also
uh on the national security council
doing terrorism and uh he was
rick grinnell's um deputy deputy dni i
think
all right the anvil says 15 years in
corrections do my job for a year and
you'll change your mind on the death
penalty that is a horrifying prospect
because my position of the death penalty
is that there are very very bad people
who deserve death but the issue isn't
the bad people who deserve death it's
the innocent people who get caught in
the system and get put to death so
if the idea was that
the robbery bill were saying robert
barnes for a.g i'd take it absolutely uh
if people are saying that or if your
idea is that i would go to a prison and
see bad people and be like well i don't
care about the innocent getting caught
up in the system anymore because these
people suck no that's a terrifying
prospect my issue is that kamala harris
is a very bad person and imagine what
kind of person kamala harris will be
given the power to uh where she had the
power to you know decide who lives or
dies i'm not saying it is her i'm saying
imagine someone like her in that
position so just think about that and
then cross your fingers and hope it's
not her because one day it will be
someone like her
not a fan of that not a fan but i don't
look i gotta admit
i don't even know if there are there's
an answer because you got to do
something with people who are duly
convicted under due process somebody
gets convicted what do you say we'll
lock them in a box for the rest of their
lives because it's better than killing
them well you could be doing that to
innocent people too and then there's
still problems
all right let's grab some more super
chats
smothers says we heart ghost and and
lady emoji
there you go thank you
the swiss army man says go state beat
iowa i-s-u-i-s-u-i-s-u
this is a i don't i don't get it i don't
get it i'm a proud hawkeye but you
didn't hear me once say that you know
iowa state uh is is an inferior football
team i never say well he says in all
seriousness though this is a great show
great that the show is attracting such
great guests
there you go so they're just well they
didn't realize how much you're paying me
to be here right oh yeah no one else
yeah we'll talk about that
yeah a whole lot of nothing
sean46 says thank you tim poole for all
your hard work great stuff please ask mr
whitaker if he appointed attorney john
durham was his son attorney john j
durham also appointed a special
prosecutor
oh i'm sorry if he appointed attorney
john durham yeah did you
i did not uh so john durham has a son
who's also a federal prosecutor
[Music]
eastern district um who worked a lot on
the ms-13 cases for us
and so it's sometimes confusing because
there's two john durms at the department
of justice
all right let's see
only one truth says research csrqsm
and ask tim poole if he has sold us all
out are you s-class tim are you
gatekeeping the truth i have no idea
what that means but it sounded funny so
i wanted to read it yeah yeah
okay anyway moving on
social media man social management
software i don't know exactly what it is
though oh no idea
all right let's uh let's grab some super
chat i don't think we're gatekeeping the
truth no i don't know we do it two and a
half like you know what i love is when
um we have people like marjorie taylor
green on and she's a member of congress
who just talks
you know there's no canned responses no
scripted talking points no list of
journalists to call from right
i don't i don't know the truth i watched
jacinda arden is that her name the new
zealand ardern being like we are the
arbiters of truth if you don't hear from
us it's not real we only the truth comes
from like dude i'll tell you what i know
or whatever
you gotta
i can't guarantee that what i've been
told is real well and most of most
things are pseudo events you know
there's very few like real events yeah
most are like press conferences or
things that are you know just created um
you know i love it the like the idea
that a corporation or a politician is
going to come and give you the truth
when a crisis happens it's like
deep water horizon spill you think
they're going to come out and tell you
the truth yeah right dude the dog could
barf on the floor and like a dude's
gonna lie to his girlfriend about it you
think a major corporation is gonna come
tell you the truth
no come on
if you can't handle like pissing off
your neighbor when he comes over and he
sees spilled trash uh must been a
raccoon you think they're gonna be like
all that oil in your in your bay and all
your shrimp getting killed or whatever
yeah you're right
all right sega infinite infinite says i
usually watch irl the day after on 1.5
speed today i'm watching live and it'll
be the first time i'll be watching the
after show as i just got my membership
this morning awesome yes
if you don't i mean this
i've saved a lot oh good for the the
after show oh good oh yeah because i
mean yeah
this has been the challenge it's like we
go through a list of like okay youtube
will ban that youtube will ban that
youtube
and so look i'll say it as i say it
often there's a lot of people who are
like stop doing your show on youtube and
it's like dude youtube dominates the the
space so we just try to create a bridge
and that bridge is you watch it here we
put articles on timcast.com we create
shows on timcast.com we have the members
only platform
the reason why it costs money to be a
member is because
it costs money to host the videos and
for us to keep going
youtube you guys super chat it keeps
things going there's ad revenue and we
i'd much prefer not to be on youtube but
i think i think of youtube as an
excellent opportunity for regular people
to get exposed to this content and then
find our website where we can have very
serious conversations watch the
conversation with march retailer green
last week yeah we were talking about
what the republicans are going to do in
november as it pertains to the 2020
election things like that
um
plus you need to be able to afford the
bourbon i'm about to drink that's right
suburban
we got some good bourbon for sure
absolutely um we don't pay our guests
but we take care of our guests
yo we've had some people uh that we've
not invited on the show respond with
like
honorariums and fees really oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah and like nobody nobody gets
paid to come on here i said yes that was
actually and then i said and then and
then we screwed up the date yeah yeah
this is how is that what happened yeah
they're like well we have these other 10
people you want to join them no
10. this is all going to be about matt
there's a whole spotlight mat
i mean this is did they should do they
get to see this oh yeah
are we saving this for the like members
no we have those that is a spitting
image that's i love it it's really good
she chooses flattering pictures that's
awesome we have it and i think i guess
that's my official picture i don't know
yeah probably probably yeah it's really
well shaded we have a wall of all of
these pictures that jessica has drawn of
everybody
involvement we wanted to like nft them
or something oh i'm like
create like a database or like back in
the day when that was a thing yeah it
still is and it is okay yeah yeah i'm
not saying we're going to get like
millions zero five ethereum yeah and
that's money or eth as you guys know if
we if we sold one and someone paid 20
bucks for the office i own some crypto i
get i don't know yeah of course what are
your favorite cryptos
uh just i'm only in uh i think bitcoin
and ethereum i do have some good ones
some stable coin let me see what it's
called bitcoin is in a league of its own
everything else is basically a stock and
a bad company um gosh darn it where is
it usd it's a gemini us dollar that's
yielding me somewhere around five six i
think you can check it i'm not i'm not
endorsing it i'm just saying i like
yield
um can't beat inflation at all right now
bitcoin took a big hit but it literally
does not matter to me i have the bitcoin
for the bitcoin not for its us value so
i've been in bitcoin since bitcoin was a
couple bucks granted i when when bitcoin
hit 20 bucks i got all excited and sold
it
like yeah i mean
yeah yep you should trust me
yeah no i'm i'm i i think it's gonna be
interesting um
how how government regulates
crypto that's gonna be a very very
interesting thing to watch because they
don't understand it and so um you know
they might just kill it um but they want
to regulate it they'll try
the thing about uh bitcoin is you can't
yeah it's like trying to ban gold it's
like yeah you can people are starting to
use it
all right leah leo mcdougall says ammon
bundy is running for governor in idaho
would be a great guest yeah interesting
would be a great guess it's very
interesting
idaho iowa ohio it's all the same
thing
michael alio says china currently is
experiencing a wave of modern feminism
but any wokeness that would affect
nationalism is heavily suppressed
interesting where do they get the idea
that they're
having feminism
take over
i know their banks are collapsing
that's particularly bad for him
i'm interested in what's on their
internet
yeah
probably i'll just pro pro communist
party stuff
a lot of people say it's like
educational content and
i don't know we got an angry one here
from box fed tv says how could you allow
rey and the fbi to get away with this
they are hunting conservatives ray
shouldn't should be in gaunt and gwant
bay
weak republicans have allowed all of
this you didn't fight who ordered the
stone raid
uh
this is my point is that that somebody
in the field office in florida
ordered the stone right or it was you
know higher up could you fire them at
fbi if you could get to who i mean this
is you know that's the
it's really hard to reach down that many
layers and you know get to fire them up
well you can't they're all i mean this
is this is several trolls
this is trump's point you have one
political appointee at the fbi forty
thousand employees and chris ray is the
only political appointee wow in order to
fire federal employees it's ridiculously
difficult yeah well the president trump
was just talking about it today uh you
know they there it takes about five
there's three levels of appeal after you
try to fire somebody each each round
takes about five years
i mean now that that's president trump
um describing you know what somebody has
probably told him or you know otherwise
but um i believe that i have i have i
know that it's very very very very hard
to get rid of a career
um but you got to get creative
you know you don't you don't just go in
and be like let's start the appeal
process we're going to be fine no
there's you can reassign people you can
move people around you can get you know
i mean obviously you got to be you know
it's it's all 40 000 in
iowa
would that would be too much federal
office
we are we already have you know sort of
probably a safe state though it would be
a very safe state too much law
enforcement though yeah
people of iowa would not want that many
fbi agents do you find that people in
law enforcement alaska look for like
look for crim crime
i mean obviously some people are but
like where it's not there like i've
heard the fbi will actually incite crime
so that they can bust people that they
think might be a problem in the future
but did you get that vibe no i didn't
get that vibe it was a
it's a target-rich environment you have
people committing crimes all day i mean
we were talking earlier about you know
the fraud threshold is how how many
million somebody has to steal before
it's a federal case i mean that's
there's that and i you know i'm not
going to tell the story because it's not
good um but just say let's just you know
say that there's there's plenty of work
for the fbi to do without you know
creating uh enticing or otherwise you
know
making people that wouldn't otherwise
commit crimes commit crimes
um
now
in the in the realm of terrorism
and people that want to do harm to our
country i i'm i'm sure
uh that there have been artifices that
have been you know employed with people
that are here illegally and you know
otherwise
don't have the same you know
constitutional rights or due process
rights but you know these are not
examples i'm giving a generic example
that i don't have exact experience with
i just think that you know once you're
talking about people that want to blow
up buildings or you know create mass
casualty events i think you know kind of
all bets are off
all right that would take it that would
take a high a high threshold to get to
that you wouldn't just do that
willy-nilly
john l says whoopi also said that jill
biden should be surge in general that
she is an excellent doctor i almost fell
off my chair when i saw the clip it's an
older clip it's making its rounds again
did you see this when she was like i
didn't but i believe it amazing and then
they're like i think she's a teacher and
she goes really i thought she was a
doctor it's like yeah she's not even
really a doctor yeah it's like an
honorary educational title or something
like that
yup yup yup
let's see paul
thongnam says want to see ian be put in
front of donald trump and talk about
graphing we can uh we can get trump on
board yeah i think it's the bridge
between the environmentalists and the
national industrialists because we can
start cleaning the air and make the
greatest graphene production facility on
earth and start selling it to the world
and become an economic powerhouse what
if like
we interview donald trump in the next
few months we go up to jersey and then
just mid show ian's just like graphene
and trump goes wait what are you talking
about and then he just goes off on this
tangent and then trump is like i'm gonna
make you graphene czar when i'm
president and then he actually does and
then you know the
guys in suits show up with a helicopter
and the lawn and they're like ian you
need to come with us that'd be cool and
then because we're gonna have to
we'll have to work together globally so
we don't take too much out of the air we
it's going to be a huge carbon from
other places man from asteroids from the
moon we got to mine the moon but i'm
starting to local burn fossil fuels yes
right actually upscale phosphate you
mine coal and then you hit with lasers
and turn it into graphene it burns
cleaner
what about boiling so i don't i don't
want to admit but this is not the first
conversation in the last five days that
i've had on this topic
yeah well just just this
the just the whole
solutions to all the world's problems oh
yeah yeah
ian's graphene is
becoming influential on it we can
fertilize the ocean with iron oxide to
regrow plankton which will cause fish
blooms and then we can fragment the
coral called microfragmentation into
thousands of particles of coral and then
you put them all near each other and it
all grows together you can reform coral
reefs we can grow new coral reefs on
mars it's gonna be fun okay all right
mavis says it's hps harry potter
syndrome leftists want to run around
pretending to be dumbledore's army not
realizing they're the death eaters
correct well considering it's the only
book they've ever read that's a that's
that's a good point
there's you can uh this is funny sheamus
points out the only book that the left
have the only books the left reads are
harry potter and the handmaid's tale but
considering they're both just had they
were both adapted into film and
television they probably just watched it
yeah uh i agree
unfortunately good i like the i agrees
michael mccord says look can i go back
and read this super chat after i'm after
we oh yeah
there's tons i can't read all of them
yeah we don't have time
all right michael mccord says look at
the text of the constitution you can
impeach any civil servant in the federal
government even better they can't serve
again
all right we'll grab a couple more here
mike cannelly says would anyone be
surprised if the documents needed to
prove hunter and joe biden's involvement
in illegal foreign affairs happens to be
in a building in ukraine that no longer
exists
uh of course i would not be surprised
probably misplaced yeah like the guest
list
all right let's grab a couple more do
you admit that though
no not our guests list a certain um guy
with an island's guest list oh yeah
ethan holloway says hey tim you tell
people to move to the country my family
is from the allegheny mountains near you
rural lifestyle appalachia poor blue
city dam have money to buy our land to
escape what makes you think they won't
ruin our way of life that's a good point
they might but um i don't think the
people that i'm talking to are those
people right the people i'm talking to
want
exactly what you're talking about so
the democrats who live in the cities who
want to flee probably aren't watching
tim cast you know so
they should be
i mean they should be and then they
should abandon their mentality yeah
exactly but i think i think the people
who watch will be like you know what
um actually i'll say this without saying
the name there's there's one of our
friends who lives in the newark area
who's talking about coming out here and
they have great values and they oppose
all the same stuff you do and
this is what i'm saying like
you can't just be scared that people are
going to come and try and corrupt your
way of life you need to actively recruit
too so
just do the best you can go to work too
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and head over to timcast.com for the
members only show we're going to talk
about a whole lot of stuff a whole lot
of crazy government insider stuff that
youtube well they would get mad at us
for and it's unfortunate but it's
reality and we're doing our best to make
sure those conversations persist so
check out timcast.com you can follow the
show at tim cast irl you can follow me
personally at tim cast matt you want to
shout anything out
uh i just would love people to give my
show liberty and justice a listen to
it's on all the podcast networks it's
also on youtube and rumble and
everything i'm doing whether it's my tv
hits
and anything else is on whitaker.tv sign
up for a newsletter
right on
you can find me on instagram or wechat
at closer kitty but more importantly i
want you to go subscribe to pop culture
crisis on youtube we go live at 3 p.m
eastern noon pacific time every monday
through friday talking about
entertainment news we keep it
light-hearted um and we don't get
political so if you want to come have
fun and not be so somber
then come join us
subscribe
and also you get to shoot money at us if
you super chat so
i highly incentivize you to do so
someone mentioned that because when the
crisis parties keep happening you guys
stay on the show longer it should be
called hostage parties yeah no literally
we are being held hostage every single
time
right that's awesome hey guys you follow
me in crossland.net get in touch with me
social media oh man i want to point
people at your at your twitter and truth
social too matt whitaker46 yes sir
people follow you there great to see you
man good to see you hi everyone very fun
show with matt this evening you guys
should especially tune in to pop culture
crisis because tomorrow i will be
guesting we're gonna talk about awesome
stuff we always do we don't talk about
politics it's a relief it's a lot of fun
and they go every they go hard every day
three to like five p.m it's awesome you
guys can follow me on twitter mines.com
at sourpatchlits as well as
sourpatchlits.me also for all of you
that are in new york go check out times
square because we have 292 96 foot tall
billboards
on a two-minute loop of all of our shows
and hosts mary's on the billboard he
ends on the billboard we got luke and
mal is back up there i'm up there
laser eyes yeah we gave we gave mary
laser eyes on the billboard because i'm
like dude if you're not ish posting like
what are you even doing and then we have
a 96 foot tall roberto junior my rooster
and then on the right panel because it's
two billboards is the cartoon of him
screaming into the sky and then the
anime rooster battle um
totally worth it this is what i'm
talking about you know somebody
mentioned the irreverence they were like
i love it and i said yeah how come
how come like we're not that successful
i mean we are successful but you take a
look at some of these bigger well-known
individuals and they don't do fun stuff
like just buy a bunch of billboards and
put clowns throwing pies i don't know
just do something right
we'll figure it out clowns throwing pies
i mean that's your next idea
i i actually i shouldn't say anything
but we have some ideas involving clowns
okay i'm just like where where's the fun
where's the where's the weird where's
the irreverence where's like the shock
to the system where's the culture jam
alex stein knows what's up all right
we'll leave it there we'll be all over
uh we'll see you all over at timcast.com
for that member show thanks for hanging
out bye guys
you